telus et hugo j'espère que vous allez
bien et aujourd'hui je vais essayer de
vous expliquer le plus clairement
possible le conflit israélo-palestinien
avec toute l'équipe on a beaucoup
travaillé ces dernières semaines pour
publier cette vidéo qui on l'espère
répondre à un maximum de vos questions
gardez en tête que c'est un sujet qui
est extrêmement complexe évidemment donc
on ne pourra pas traiter toutes les
dimensions de ce sujet mais on va en
fait se pencher sur les éléments
principaux
et si c'est du coup une vidéo qui vous
plaît n'hésitez pas à le dire dans les
commentaires
et à vous abonner à cette nouvelle
chaîne youtube hugues décrypte pour ne
pas louper les vidéos suivantes qui
arrive
alors pour comprendre les tensions
actuelles on est obligé de revenir au
moins 100 ans en arrière à la fin du 19e
siècle il n'y a pas d' israël mais par
contre il y à bien la palestine une
province de ce qui s'appelait l empire
ottoman et où habite à ce moment là une
population arabe composée de 80 % de
musulmans environ 10% de chrétiens et
10% de juifs faut savoir qu'au même
moment en europe dans de nombreux pays
l'antisémitisme est très présent les
juifs sont persécutés et certains vont
donc fuir vers la palestine pourquoi en
palestine et pourquoi pas autre part
et bien c'est un territoire qui est très
symbolique pour les juifs car il
correspond selon la tradition juive à la
terre promise par dieu à abraham le père
du judaïsme et à ses descendants
c'est donc à cette période que va
commencer à naître un mouvement ce
mouvement c'est ce que l'on appelle le
sionisme
concrètement le sionisme c'est quoi
c'est un mouvement politique qui a pour
objectif de donner aux juifs un
territoire national dans la région où se
trouve la palestine on avance un peu
dans l'histoire on est désormais en 1914
cédant 1914 qui éclate donc la première
guerre mondiale la grande bretagne
rentrer en guerre contre l' empire
ottoman qui contrôlent donc à ce moment
là la palestine est en plein conflit est
bien le gouvernement britannique promet
aux juifs de son pays
un foyer pour eux directement en
palestine
en 1918 la première guerre mondiale
prend fin l'empiré ottoman ces fonds et
deux ans plus tard c'est donc le royaume
uni qui prend le contrôle de ce
territoire palestinien
180 mille juifs s'installent alors en
palestine entre 1929 et 1939 et à ce
moment là un certain nombre d'arabes de
la région qu'ils soient musulmans
chrétiens voient c'est arrivé plus tôt
d'un mauvais oeil
il ya donc une résistance qui va
s'organiser et des révoltes qui vont se
succéder
en 1939 la seconde guerre mondiale
éclate
millions de juifs sont tués par les
nazis l'immigration juive vers la
palestine saxons dessus et avec ça et
bien les tensions entre juifs d'un côté
et arabe de l'autre côté ne s'arrête pas
dans les années qui viennent
en 1947 pour tenter de calmer la
situation qui est logiquement très
étendus et complexes et bien
l'organisation des nations unies va
adopter à ce moment là un plan et ce
plan en 1947 il prévoit la création sur
le territoire palestinien d'un état juif
israël et d'un état arabe la palestine
résolution
ce plan de l'organisation des nations
unies de création comme ça de deux états
est acceptée par la communauté juive de
palestine mais il est rejeté par la
communauté arabe de la région à cette
époque en fait en palestine vivent un
million trois cent mille arabes et six
cent mille juifs
or dans ce plan est bien l'état d'israël
doit récupérer 55 % du territoire avec
donc une population pourtant plus
faibles dans la communauté arabo
musulmane à ce moment là c'est donc le
sentiment d'une profonde injustice qui
est présente une injustice puisque il
estime qu'on leur vole leurs terres à ce
moment là donc les désaccords sont
nombreux rien n'est acté et pourtant
quelques mois plus tard le 14 mai 1948
ben gourion un des leaders du mouvement
sioniste proclame la création de l'état
d'israël sans l'accord donc des autres
pays arabes de la région
on n a pas arrivé
au lendemain de la création de l'état
d'israël en 1948 l'egypte la jordanie
l'irak le liban ou encore la syrie
déclara la guerre à israël car ils
n'approuvent pas tout simplement la
création de leur état
cette galère c'est ce que l'on appelle
la première guerre israélo-arabe et la
durée de 1948 à 1949 est l'objectif de
ces pays c'est de reprendre la main sur
les territoires attribués à israël pour
faire en sorte de créer une palestine
arabe
au bout d'un an et bien israël va gagner
la guerre est annexée la moitié ouest de
jérusalem une ville qui est donc
pourtant je le disais à l'instant sous
contrôle international met donc ce
territoire va être annexés par israël
ainsi que d'ailleurs une grande majorité
des territoires qui avait été attribuée
aux palestiniens par l'organisation des
nations unies en 1948
le résultat c'est quoi et bien face à
cette nouvelle perte très importante de
territoire plus de sept cent mille
palestiniens vont quitter leur foyer et
s'exiler dans les pays arabes voisins il
ya notamment la jordanie la syrie ou
encore le liban et cet exode massif
il a un nom la nakba ce qui veut dire
donc catastrophe en arabe
bref beaucoup de changements beaucoup
d'évolutions au fil de ces années mais
pour résumer à la fin de la guerre en
1949 il ne reste désormais que deux
territoires qui ne sont pas contrôlés
par israël
ces deux territoires c'est la bande de
gaza qui est sous contrôle de l'égypte
et la cisjordanie qui est contrôlé par
la jordanie
malheureusement cette première guerre
n'est que le début du conflit
israélo-arabe et si on avance un peu
dans le temps en 1967 une nouvelle
guerre éclate entre israël et ses
voisins
et c'est la guerre des six jours alors
comme son nom l'indiqué la guerre des
six jours elle va durer seulement six
jours jusqu ici c'est assez logique mais
en l'occurrence le bilan est très très
élevé on compte environ 750 morts côté
israélien et plus de 20000 morts du côté
des pays arabes israël va gagner la
guerre et a cependant la prendre le
contrôle de plusieurs territoires
ces territoires repris par israël vous
les voyez donc actuellement à l'écran il
ya la bande de gaza et la péninsule du
sinaï qui était jusqu'ici contrôlé par
l'egypte il ya aussi le plateau du golan
qui était contrôlée par la syrie et
enfin il aussi la cisjordanie qui était
contrôlée par la jordanie est donc là
que israël reprend à nouveau
par ailleurs israël va accentuer sa
mainmise sur la ville de jérusalem
puisque le pays va occupé et annexé
jérusalem est et va faire voter une loi
pour instaurer une réunification des
deux côtés de jérusalem jérusalem est et
jérusalem ouest pour en faire la
capitale de l'état d'israël
1967 guerre des six-jours l'autre date à
retenir c'est donc 1973 la guerre du
kippour
elle va éclater cette fois ci entre eux
israël d'un côté une alliance entre
l'egypte et la syrie
de l'autre côté en fait l'egypte la
syrie veulent tout simplement récupérer
les territoires qu'ils avaient perdu
depuis la guerre des six jours
le truc c'est que israël va à nouveau
gagner la guerre avec plus de 20000
pertes du côté arabe contre environ 2500
à 7500 côté israélien mais donc beaucoup
moins jeunes en l'occurrence c'est
important de comprendre que à ce moment
là les deux pays arabes ne sont pas
complètement perdant puisque avec cette
guerre ils ont créé un climat
d'incertitude
on y sera
elle est tout ça va pousser d'une
certaine façon israël à dialoguer avec
les pays voisins
conséquence israël va rendre une partie
du plateau du golan à la syrie en 1974
puis évacué peu à peu le sinaï pour
l'egypte en échange de la promesse
égyptienne qu'il n'attaque plus israël
et quant à la bande de gaza et la
cisjordanie est bien à ce moment-là elle
reste occupé militairement par israël
la cisjordanie et la bande de gaza sont
donc occupés militairement par israël à
ce moment là en 1974
et c'est dans ces territoires occupés
qu'ont lieu les différentes et si fade à
ce qui signifie soulèvement en arabe
pour faire simple ce sont donc des
mouvements d'opposition des palestiniens
contre l'occupation israélienne
tu as donc une première intifada en 1987
nouvelles dates à retenir qui est assez
importante et cette première intifada
prend fin en 1993 avec ce que l'on
appelle les accords d'oslo roar ces
accords d'oslo en 1993 ils vont faire
naître une sorte de lueur d'espoir
puisque et bien le gouvernement
israélien va reconnaître l'organisation
de libération palestinienne comme
représentant du peuple palestinien et de
l'autre côté et bien l'organisation de
libération palestinienne va reconnaître
le droit d'israël d'exister
le problème pour faire vraiment très
simple c'est que cet accord ne va jamais
vraiment existé
puisque en israël eh bien les mouvements
de droite pour s'opposer à cet accord et
du côté de la palestine est bien le
mouvement islamiste palestinien du hamas
s'oppose lui aussi à tout ça résultat il
ya donc une seconde intifada qui se
déroule elle a lieu entre 2000 et 2005
ça a été la plus meurtrière
plus de 3000 morts côté palestinien et
plus de 1000 côté israélien
notamment à cause d'attentats suicide
palestiniens et deux frappes aériennes
de l'armée y sera
m
alors on entend beaucoup parler dans
l'actualité de la bande de gaza pourquoi
et bien c'est très simple
en 2005 l'armée israélienne va
finalement quitter cette bande de gaza
et deux ans plus tard le hamas considéré
comme une organisation terroriste par
beaucoup de pays dont l'union européenne
va prendre le pouvoir sur ce territoire
palestinien
un blocus est alors met en place par
israël sur la bande de gaza ce blocus il
a pour objectif de limiter l'importation
de produits sur le territoire ou encore
de limiter l'alimentation en électricité
et en eau pour les habitants de gaza et
les conséquences d'un point de vue
humanitaire sont très importantes
on compte notamment un chômage qui est
très important aujourd'hui sur ce
territoire dans les années qui vont
suivre va y avoir donc des oppositions
régulière au centre de gaza avec d'un
côté le hamas et de l'autre côté l'armée
israélienne il ya une première guerre en
2008 2009 une seconde en 2012 ou une
troisième encore en 2014
et sur ces trois guerre de gaza on
compte environ 85 morts côté israélien
et plus de 3500 morts côté palestinien
où
cette question du décalage entre le
bilan sur le nombre de décès c'est une
question qui est importante pourquoi
est-ce qu'il ya plus de morts côté
palestinien que côté israélien lord ces
conflits
des milliers de roquettes sont tirées
depuis gaza vers israël
des roquettes dont qui viennent du hamas
mais israël va en fait intercepter un
très grand nombre de ces roquettes
grâce au dôme de fer un système
d'interception des roquettes qui a été
mise en place en 2011
en gros ce dôme de fer repères et
neutralise les missiles en plein air et
les empêche ainsi donc d'exploser en
israël
ce dôme de fer il est très efficace mais
il est aussi très coûteux puisque pour
chaque requête envoyée par le hamas et
qui est stoppé par israël il faut
compter environ 50000 euros par
utilisation est donc c'est quelque chose
de très coûteux mais en l'occurrence et
bien israël est allié aux états unis et
c'est bien les états unis qui finance en
partie ce dôme de fer c'est d'ailleurs
l'élément qui est beaucoup avancé par le
hamas pour expliquer cette différence
sur le bilan le fait qu' israël est
beaucoup plus équipés tout de même est
notamment soutenu par les états unis
aujourd'hui
alors quand on écoute les dirigeants
israéliens concernant cette différence
de bilan et le nombre de morts plus fort
et plus important disons côté
palestinien et bien israël va répondre
que c'est surtout de la faute du hamas
qui utiliserait ce qu'ils appellent des
boucliers humains très complètement les
autorités israéliennes accusent le hamas
de cacher les armes les lancements de
roquettes
et c'est à proximité de la population
palestinienne
par exemple dans des écoles des maisons
ou même des hôpitaux et à cela de son
côté le hamas nie ces accusations et
certains spécialistes estiment qu'il
serait de toute façon difficile de
limiter les victimes de frappes
israéliennes dans une zone aussi
densément peuplées que gaza autrement
dit donc selon as beaucoup de
spécialistes s'il ya des frappes
israéliennes sur gaza
les conséquences sont quasi
inévitablement des décès aussi au sein
de la population de la zone
alors maintenant qu'on a vu le contexte
très large est vu un peu l'évolution
progressive de la situation ce qu'aime
essentiel de comprendre qu'est ce qui
s'est passé récemment et bien la
nouvelle flambée de violence que l'on a
observé en mai a commencé tout
simplement avec l'ordre d'expulsion de
plusieurs familles palestiniennes de
leurs maisons des familles
palestiniennes dont les maisons étaient
situées dans le quartier de jérusalem
est ce je le disais tout à l'heure l'est
de la ville de jérusalem est occupée et
annexée par israël
sauf que des familles palestiniennes y
vivent toujours
et ces familles sont donc menacés
d'expulsion par des israéliens qualifiés
de colons qui prétendent qu'il s'agit de
leur territoire et qui veulent
s'installer à leur place en fait pour
faire très simple l'organisation des
nations unis s'opposent à ces menaces
d'expulsion venant d'israël contre ces
familles palestiniennes
ce sont d'ailleurs des menaces qui
pourraient d'après l'onu être
considérées comme des crimes de guerre
contre les palestiniens
c'est donc après cet événement comme
point de départ que se sont intensifié
les tensions ces derniers jours il ya eu
environ dix jours d'affrontements très
violent et un cessez le feu a été a
finalement conclu entre israël et le
hamas
le soir du 20 mai au bout de dix jours
ces affrontements auront donc fait
environ 230 morts côté palestinien dont
des enfants et douze morts côté
israélien
alors vous l'aurez compris les tensions
sont toujours très présentes entre
israéliens et palestiniens et à
l'étranger on craint une reprise des
affrontements à tout moment faut bien
comprendre qu une part assez importante
des pays du monde dont les pays de
l'union européenne se disent favorables
à une solution à deux états donc un état
israélien et un état palestinien mais en
fait derrière ces mots certains jugent
que les gouvernements manquent de
courage et de volonté pour réellement
parvenir à la paix et parvenir
à la création d'un état palestinien en
plus donc d'un état israélien
en tout cas cette vidéo vous a permis
d'y voir un peu plus clair et bien
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner pour ne pas
rater nos vidéos suivantes
évidemment c'est impossible de résumer
un conflit pareil en seulement 20
minutes notamment en mettant le plus de
nuances possibles mais ça me paraissait
quand même assez essentiel de répondre
un certain nombre de questions et
d'éclaircir certains points qui peuvent
paraître assez floue aujourd'hui bref du
coup ce sujet complexe qui mérite qu'on
s'y penche encore davantage du coup ça
vous intéresse je vous mets en
descriptions des ouvrages des
documentaires etc qui pourraient vous
intéresser
n'hésitez pas aussi à découvrir les
autres vidéos postées sur cette nouvelle
chaîne youtube
hugo décrypte notamment la rencontre
avec l'ex directeur de la cia rien que
ça et puis voilà je crois que tout dit
prenez soin de vous présenter aux
proches
on se dit à très vite pour une nouvelle
vidéo sur cette chaîne
[Musique]